now I do I I do stand up still I do
whatever you know try to do movies here
and there now with the talk show I do a
lot that's tougher than I thought just
talking then you thought or no okay
you're gonna hate my answer I was
terrified to do this and it is way
easier than I thought oh it is yeah well
tell me the secret because I think I'm
trying too hard
no I don't that's what it is that's the
big you know I had this conversation
with other hosts yeah I think I
genuinely really like even jerks I like
getting in there and trying to it's a
challenge to kind of win them over oh
you know what I think maybe the tough
part is cuz I cry every night and it's
not always about that but I I i
sometimes because ours is like three
comedians and then we have topics of the
day and we talk about it and then we do
jokes and stuff so I sort of have to
prep more and it and and maybe I wanna I
just put I get up early listen I'm no
workaholic you might as well know now so
all my friends know this so I just
thought who I Breeze in at what twelve
leave at 12:40 that sounds like a good
job and I also made them pay me in a
casino chips it's so stupid
I have to drive up to morongo every
weekend so it's a little harder than I
thought but I do love it it's fun to do
a job like you seem like you love this
and it's nice because I get I'm a
comedian song around funny people where
the writers are funny and I bring great
people on so it's overall it's a good
time subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going